[Music]
on this thursday night nova scotia's
heartbreak
before the holidays families of six men
lost at sea
face an agonizing weight one of the moms
said
i know that he may not come home the way
i want but
somebody please bring him home the
investigation into why the scallop
fishing boat
sank climbing kobit 19 cases new calls
for tighter restrictions in ontario as
alberta plans a field hospital close to
being
cleared for takeoff boeing 737 max jets
could be back in canada's skies
soon plus consequences and crashes
millions of americans caught in a
monster winter storm
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in nova scotia where
families who make their living at sea
are facing a devastating loss all six
crew members on board the scallop
fishing boat that went down in rough
seas on tuesday morning
are now presumed dead the men were on
their way back to port and digby their
boat loaded with scallops
when something went wrong the company
that owns the boat says the crew did not
issue a distress call only one body has
been recovered
and the search for the others has been
suspended because of bad weather
prolonging the agony for their families
ross lord has our top story
tonight
weather is working against efforts to
recover more evidence and return
victims bodies to their families a
stormy forecast forced
rcmp to suspend wednesday's operation we
have an impending snowstorm
which has made it you know dangerous for
for for us to to continue making the
anguish
even worse for families of the six scala
harvesters
one of the moms said you know i i know
um i know that he may not come home
the way i want but somebody please bring
him home
and that alone would be some closure
michelle nickerson
a mother of two who lost her husband
posted a gracious message
thanking searchers and supporters our
family thanks every one of you for your
prayers
she added rest peacefully boys wherever
you lie tonight
the boat owner yarmouth sea products
says the crew had been fishing for four
days
the company suggests stormy conditions
forced them to head home
they've been traveling for five hours
before their boat the chief william
solis
went down the community right now i
would
say is in a state of
numbness there's no other words to
express
it for investigators the focus is
shifting from what happened
to why the transportation safety board
has arrived
to inspect debris and other evidence
being stored here at the bridgetown rcmp
detachment
to inflatable life rafts but at this
point we
we've only uh had a quick look at them
we have not been able to
positively confirm that they are from
the vessel the sinking of the chief
william solis
is the latest in a long line of
tragedies at sea in nova scotia
including the miss alley capsizing in
2013 which killed five men
safety advisors insist since miss alley
awareness and protection have improved
we've
come up with new technologies and safety
equipment to keep aboard the vessel the
safety board says the use of protective
gear
and a boat's condition are included in
every investigation
with christmas approaching fundraisers
are underway to help families of the six
men
some organized by friends others by
complete strangers
looking for ways to help communities and
a province plagued by tragedy
ross lord global news hillsborough nova
scotia
as we approach the holiday season the
second wave of kovid 19 keeps taking a
toll across this country
more than 7 000 people have tested
positive for the virus just in a single
day
and more than 110 canadians are reported
to have died from it today
ontario reported the most new cases of
any province today more than 2400 that
is a daily record
and 23 more ontarians have died this is
the path ontario is on when it comes to
active cases more than 17
400 ontarians are dealing with the virus
of those 263
are extremely ill in intensive care that
is the highest number of covet icu
patients in ontario
since april 172 of those people
are on ventilators the group
representing ontario hospital says it is
near the breaking point and
wants immediate action taken it's asked
premier doug ford to impose as a minimum
a four-week lockdown in regions with the
highest infection rates
in a statement the ontario hospital
association says we are now in the
holiday season and if members of the
public choose to ignore public health
measures
and gather outside their households the
consequences risk
overwhelming ontario's hospitals premier
ford said today he welcomes the hospital
association's input
he says his government is listening to
public health advice and that everything
is on the table including
potentially setting up what ford calls
interim hospitals
to help relieve the pressure when i
talked to a doc yesterday
and he's he told me that he was talking
you know he had to cancel a surgery for
a 42 year old
male patient that has cancer you know
that that
that we just can't keep going in the way
we're going and because the icu beds are
taking out from co-vet patients
in alberta hospitals are already
overwhelmed that province has called in
the red cross to help set up a field
hospital in edmonton
the chief medical officer of health
calls it a precaution
heather urex west looks at what could be
coming as alberta heads into the
holidays
it's a building known by many names
officially called the universidad
pavilion
dubbed the butter dome because of how it
looks
soon it will house a field hospital
though alberta officials
aren't calling it that ahs is also
working with the canadian red cross
to set up an alternate care center at
the butter dome on the university of
alberta's campus
whatever you call it the 100 bed
facility is being constructed
because of covet 19. alberta has seen
the number of covet patients in hospital
double
every three weeks since early november
on november 2nd there were 119
patients in acute care and 28 in icu
six weeks later those numbers grew to
610 and 139
alberta health services is now adding
another 2 250 acute care
and 425 icu beds but there are fears
that even with new restrictions
these beds could soon fill as well we
can expect hospitalizations
and intensive care unit admissions to
continue to go up for the next several
weeks here in alberta
even if the daily numbers begin to
plateau so
we have to prepare for what we know is
coming alberta's health minister says
the field hospital
is just contingency planning we'll
continue to make sure that
not only are we making sure we have
capacity for
our current forecasting but of course we
want to take steps
to um to to take uh to develop
contingency plans as well
which is only prudent planning now there
are signs that recent restrictions in
alberta
are working but if people gather next
week over christmas
all that progress could be wiped out my
concern is that in about
two weeks i suspect that we're going to
see another surge
similar to what happened after
thanksgiving
a post-holiday bump could be more than
enough to push
a struggling health system over the edge
heather urex west global news
calgary in quebec elementary and high
school students are home for an extended
winter holiday as new
restrictions take effect there schools
are closed until january 11th in quebec
and more regions are now in the red zone
meaning
restaurant dining rooms bars and gyms
are closed and all
non-essential businesses must close for
two weeks starting
on christmas day things are different in
canada's smallest province prince edward
island with just one
confirmed new case today the province
has decided to ease restrictions
starting tomorrow households in pei can
have up to 10 visitors
indoor dining can resume and gyms and
museums can operate
at 50 capacity
a second vaccine the one made by moderna
has moved a big step closer to
authorization
in the u.s an independent committee is
recommending the us food and drug
administration approve the vaccine for
emergency use
more than 17 million americans have now
tested positive for the virus
and more than 317 000 americans have
died from it
as jennifer johnson reports if the fda
agrees millions of doses of the modern
vaccine
could be shipped as early as this
weekend for the second time in just over
a week a panel of scientists advising
the u.s food and drug administration
recommended another cobin 19 vaccine
this one produced by moderna which is 94
percent effective
we found no cases suggestive of
anaphylaxis
to mrna 1273. the fda is likely to take
quick action
as it did with the pfizer biontech
vaccine the last shipments of the first
run of that vaccine have been delivered
and millions of healthcare workers and
nursing home residents are being
inoculated
hospitals have even found extra doses in
the vials
is that really a cause for celebration
it is um
you know really the the weapon that we
needed
to fight this pandemic for the first
time in the u.s
a health care worker in alaska had a
severe allergic reaction to the vaccine
and was hospitalized for observation
as deaths skyrocket many states are in
crisis
california's governor has activated the
state's mass fatality program
putting 60 mobile morgues on standby
overworked nurses in southern california
are threatening to go on strike
christmas eve in los angeles county
ambulances are waiting up to six
hours to offload patients at hospitals
people are going to die
that don't need to die the governor of
new york is warning he may have to shut
down his entire state
within a month if this surge continues
if we're smart
we can slow the spread if we slow the
spread
we can avoid any more economic shutdowns
it's a scenario playing out across the
country death
suffering and millions losing their jobs
and businesses
i took every bit of money that i had
and dumped it back in here to keep it
alive and
i just i can't u.s jobless numbers
thursday hit their highest level since
early september
as congress continues work on a 900
billion dollar economic aid package
leaders say they will not leave town for
the holiday break without a deal
jennifer johnson global news washington
change is in the air for the boeing 737
max
coming up what needs to happen before
transport canada clears them for takeoff
boeing's 737 max aircraft is one step
closer to returning to canadian skies
transport canada has approved design
changes and further approvals are
expected in january
all 737 max jets were grounded after two
of them crashed
killing 346 people including 18
canadians
as abigail beeman explains families of
the victims say the changes
aren't enough when i went to the crash
site i was not even able to recover the
remains so which was again
the first thing that happened to me when
the boeing 737 max
crashed in ethiopia after takeoff in
march 2019
manon fadia lost six of his family
members
even somebody offered me like 100
millions of dollars i wouldn't i
wouldn't go into that plane
but following in the footsteps of the
u.s and europe ottawa has now taken the
next steps to allow those planes to fly
approving design changes with the 737
max expected to be flying early in 2021
it means that we accept the
modifications but we also have
some canadian modifications
transport canada is requiring more
changes training and maintenance
namely allowing the pilot to override
what's called the stick
shaker warning system in both deadly
crashes the pilots weren't able to
as faulty software sent the plane into a
nosedive
the pilot who would be trained on this
and be very much aware of it since
they're flying at 737 max would be able
to
quickly and easily turn off the system
take control as a pilot and fly it
safely we're all very disappointed
robert clifford represents many of the
canadian families in a case at the u.s
federal court in chicago there's
uh no transparency to the decision
making
and that's a special concern because
as of today we've yet to receive the
final
crash report out of ethiopia to know
that
the people with authority could have
done something that's the part that's
that's so troubling
and we have a plane right now the max
that has all these grandfathered
hazards on it asked to respond to the
family's concerns boeing declined an
interview but told global news in a
statement the lessons learned from the
crashes have
reshaped the company and they're working
with regulators to
safely return the planes to service
abigail beeman
global news ottawa safety is behind the
canadian military's plan to replace its
entire fleet of polaris aircraft
including the plane the prime minister
uses our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson has news about this tonight
mercedes donna the government is finally
replacing the fleet of old
inefficient planes that fly the prime
minister transport our troops
and conduct air-to-air refueling of
canadian and
coalition fighter jets the five 33 year
old planes
were originally flown by ward air in the
1980s
even acting now they'll likely be 40
before they're retired
the age of the aircraft means constant
and expensive maintenance
as well as dated infrastructure the
prime minister's plane has
no wi-fi one phone that often doesn't
work
and pieces of plastic sometimes fall off
the inside of the plane when it lands
a senior government official says the
government plans to
buy five to six new planes to replace
the fleet
the government expects to spend between
one and nearly five billion dollars on
the project
they will be bought from a commercial
aircraft manufacturer
like boeing or airbus donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks the federal government is
providing temporary debt relief to
newfoundland and labrador for the
troubled muskrat falls hydroelectric
project
the financial help saves newfoundland
and labrador from borrowing 844 million
dollars in payments
the province's projected deficit already
stands at 1.84 billion dollars
a senior government advisor is also
being appointed to oversee the project's
financial restructuring
a major change in finances is needed to
help prevent electricity rates from
nearly doubling by 2022.
the muskrat falls project was approved
in 2012 at a cost of 7.4 billion dollars
but the price tag
has ballooned to 13 billion dollars
because of delays
and cost overruns the calls to cancel
christmas still ahead why medical
experts say easing holiday restrictions
in europe
is a bad idea
in britain more than 138 000 people have
been vaccinated for covid19 so far and
that includes actor sir ian mckellen
he's part of the first group eligible to
get the shot which includes people over
80
healthcare workers and care home
residents mckellen says he will still
wear a mask and practice physical
distancing but
said he feels euphoric to get vaccinated
i am feeling so happy and relieved and
optimistic
and everything that i haven't been
really feeling for a long time now
i couldn't be happier the french
president emmanuel macron is the latest
world leader to test positive for the
virus several other politicians are
self-isolating because they'd been in
close contact with him
europe is trying to contain this second
wave many countries are tightening
restrictions over the holidays but
some are giving people a break to gather
over christmas
and public health experts fear that is a
big mistake
redmond shannon reports london is now in
the uk's highest
lockdown level it's fed up residents
looking ahead to a proposed
five-day christmas break from
restrictions i think it's a good idea
for people's mental health i think we
need to see our families it's been a
tough year
but this week two medical journals
warned that a holiday easing of rules
could have lasting consequences we are
literally being inundated and i do not
use that word lightly
with reports of hospitals coming pretty
close to falling over the problem will
be
the sheer number of extra patients we've
covered
crowding out those with anything other
than the most
urgent medical need they will result in
a lot of suffering
and in some cases they will result in
death prime minister boris johnson
resisted opposition calls to review the
christmas reprieve
that is how by being sensible and
cautious
not by imposing endless lockdowns or
cancelling christmas as
he would appear to want to do leaders in
wales and scotland have pleaded with
residents
asking that they try to mix with fewer
people
for fewer days than the uk's christmas
rules
allow in lockdown
across europe countries like the
netherlands and germany are also
in full lockdown mode both nations are
allowing
three days at christmas where rules will
be relaxed
the news that french president emmanuel
macron has tested positive
is another reminder of how the virus
cares little for status
and how it thrives on human contact his
office says he likely became infected at
this summit last week where social
distancing
was way down the order of business a
raft of european leaders whom
macron met then and since have had to
isolate while waiting for test results
the 42 year old is said to be tired and
has a cough
his wife brigitte has so far tested
negative
redmond shannon global news london
in a rare move sweden's king is sharply
criticizing his country's handling of
the pandemic
king carl the 16th gustav says his
country failed to save lives with its
relaxed approach to covet 19.
it never imposed a full lockdown relying
mainly on its citizens sense of
civic duty to slow the spread the policy
widely supported by swedes is being
blamed now for a high death toll
among seniors and care homes the country
has reported more than 7 800 deaths
nearly four times
more than the rest of the nordic
countries combined
next the dangerous aftermath after u.s
winter storm
you're watching global national
[Music]
it is mid-december so snowstorms are no
surprise but the one hitting the
northeastern u.s
is one of the most powerful in years
this is what one new york man found when
he opened his garage this morning
a wall of snow tens of millions of
americans are under winter weather
alerts
in new york city at least 16 centimeters
of snow fell
in the last 24 hours that's a record and
is more
than new york saw all of last winter
it led to terrible driving conditions
and hundreds of car accidents
you can show me clear from this accident
a dash cam caught the moment a
pennsylvania driver lost control
on an icy road narrowly missing several
people
at least three people have died in
accidents in that state
in maryland spirit airline passengers
had a scare when their plane skidded off
the runway
no one was hurt more than 1200 flights
though have been canceled because of the
storm
the severe weather is slowing down
holiday deliveries but officials say it
will not disrupt
distribution of coronavirus vaccines we
expect
to keep getting the deliveries
and keep being able to turn around and
get people vaccinated
at least eight states have temporarily
shut down some covid19
testing sites the weather system has now
moved into atlantic canada where
snowfall warnings are in place
in several areas the royal family will
be celebrating christmas
differently this year but some
traditions are being kept up the royal
christmas cards are out and the look is
casual prince charles and camilla posed
in the garden of burke hall their
scottish estate
prince william kate and their three
children kept it casual too posing
at their home in norfolk where they
spent most of the year their youngest
prince louie
stealing the show and that is global
national for this thursday
i am fortunate to be able to take some
time off over the holiday season and i'm
sticking close to home which makes
this little yorkie happy to all of you
who will work
right through the season in health care
in long term care
in grocery stores and restaurants and
doing deliveries thank you
we can't survive without you keep safe
find joy where you can
2020 is almost over and i'll see you
again in 2021
for now bye-bye